[Applause]
on a cold cloudy key of mourning
families and friends celebrate a new
Union
it's a case of love between the air raid
sirens the bride and groom had to wait
for the all clear before they could say
their vows
inside small groups wait patiently for
more ceremonies delayed by the sirens
it's yet another intrusion of War into
everyday life here
but everyday life must and does go on
for Bogdan and Elona that includes
falling in love and getting married
[Applause]
we came here expecting to concentrate on
young couples like Alana and Bogdan
setting out on married life in the face
of War but in the end it was another
more complicated love story that seemed
to speak more to these strange and
dangerous times
it's the story of Roman and miroslava
here with no family no Fanfare they were
first married 25 years ago they divorced
but carried on living together with
Roman and their adult son both risking
their lives on the front lines now it
was time to make it official again
I would marry my wife again with or
without the war but the war affects me
of course I see how my comrades die and
it's hard all of us need to be together
Romana sniper is on 10 days leave from
fighting near the city of zaporizia
their 23 year old son Maxim is also in
the Army part of a drone unit
the wedding car isn't waiting for Roman
and miroslava they're taking the metro
to Maxim's rented flat
and it's there in the middle of one of
kiev's many power cuts that the light
and warmth of this marriage shines
through romance sisters and their
families have prepared a wedding Feast
at first we thought it's not important
we still live together but after the
signing the papers it gives a new
feeling right what do you think
I'm 22 again like when I first got
married
it's different first night love and all
that Raman says he needs to get back
soon to his guys on the front line both
of them understand that this moment is
fleeting but this relationship between
two older and wiser second time
newlyweds is anything but Harry Fawcett
Al Jazeera Kiev